on les appelle les normes post fukushima
une série de mesures visant à renforcer
la sécurité des centrales nucléaires
françaises
une petite révolution dans le monde du
nucléaire car il a fallu imaginer
l'inimaginable pour paraphraser l'ancien
patron de lierre sn l'institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
une force d'action rapide du nucléaire a
par exemple été créé il s'agit d'une
équipe de 300 personnes formées pour
intervenir en moins de 24 heures sur
n'importe quel site en difficulté puis
l'asn l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire le
gendarme du nucléaire a demandé à edf de
mettre en place un dispositif permettant
de garantir l'alimentation électrique et
le refroidissement des réacteurs
même en cas d'événements extrêmes ce que
l'on appelle les des us les diesels
d'ultime secours mais il reste encore
beaucoup à faire et certaines ong comme
greenpeace s'inquiète de la lenteur de
la mise en place des dispositifs
dix ans après la catastrophe 123 mesures
structurantes identifier seuls 12 ont
été mises en place sur l'ensemble du
parc pire autre rythme actuellement
prévus il faudrait attendre 2039 pour
que les normes post fukushima soit enfin
respectée sur l'ensemble des réacteurs
français
il faut dire que pour edf le chantier
est colossal et les travaux se sont
parfois avérée plus compliquée que prévu
certaines mesures comme l'installation
des sources d'eau ultime pour chaque
réacteur ou encore le déploiement des
centres de gestion de crise bunkérisé
ces dispositifs devraient être achevés
entre 2022 et 2026 une troisième phase
de chantier devrait aussi bientôt
s'ouvrir pour compléter la batterie de
mesures
l'irsn vise 2034 c'est en tout cas ce
qu'a déclaré l'adjoint du directeur de
l' expertise de sûreté à l'irsn à nos
confrères de france info
les aménagements post fukushima sont
donc toujours en cours dans certaines
centrales nucléaires françaises c'est le
cas par exemple ici la centrale de
gravelines qui se trouve juste derrière
moi est le plus grand site nucléaire
d'europe de l'ouest
ici un chantier a été lancé en janvier
dernier par edf
un mur devrait être érigé autour du
bâtiment il vise à éviter toute
innovation du site
si certaines ong demandent à l'état de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
accélérer le calendrier des chantiers
post fukushima l'irsn se veut rassurante
si edf et tout ce qu'il a prévu de faire
alors les centrales auront un noyau dur
complet mais c'est est ambitieux et cela
prendra encore du temps
fin de citation
[Musique]